[Music]
sunday's massive turnout put
paid to the notion that momentum had
gone from the street
a march for a new belarus it was called
but the old regime clings on propped up
by fear
and the threat of brute force belarus
has refused to give numerous journalists
including sky news
accreditation to enter the country
so we spent a week undercover in minsk
listening to people's stories
to the tales of brutality meted out on
so many of the seven
thousand detained since the contested
election results
the harrowing audiophiles of the sounds
of torture
coming from the accrestina prison shared
across the nation
soundtrack to its trauma
[Applause]
and if this protest movement was
inspired and led by women
they were not spared allianz chabinskaya
ducked out of hospital to meet us
she has been there for a week being
treated for internal injuries after she
was beaten by a female guard
what do you remember about what happened
in a made-for-tv show of strength
alexander lukashenko appeared
brandishing an assault rifle and in full
riot gear after sunday's demonstration
dismissing protesters as rats he has
long tried to blame domestic unrest
on foreign powers and his security
forces seem to believe it
mary was also held at a questioner 36
people in a cell for four at one point
she says she was amazed at the way the
guards were thinking
right from the moment we were detained
for
two and a half days in the detention
center we
kept hearing one thing over and over
again that we got paid
that we are some western agents that how
there we are to betray our country
for like 50 euros they were sure that
each and every one of us had 50 euros in
our front pocket
and uh they also kept constantly saying
that
you girls you should stay at home
uh cook borsch uh bake cakes
and uh it's not it's not your business
why even you dare to take part in it
there are some cracks in the ranks of
the police alexander akramchek resigned
this week
shocked at how brutal his colleagues
across the country had been
yes
[Music]
but it will take more than a few
defections to tip the balance
with some flamboyance lukashenko has put
the army on high alert supposedly he
claims to protect against nato and the
west
that is as much a warning to his
domestic audience as it is the mark of a
paranoid mind
the president clearly trying to turn the
hatred of his own people towards him
into a geopolitical issue which
it patently is not with so much force
and the apparatus of the state still at
his disposal
it is difficult to see where this
protest movement goes
the clamor from the street that
lukashenka leave for now
falling on deaf ears danny magne sky
news
minsk